yeah thank you Joy yes we're here with
Anish Anish the game finished in the
draw but first of all how do you assess
your tournament situation and the
overall situation are you thinking about
it and calculating all possible lines
yeah I think uh instead of calculating
the variations I've been calculating the
I calculating the wrong things uh but it
was uh a very interesting situation in
terms of candidates qualification I
think it would be really interesting if
people were following it much more
closely instead um
uh you know my colleagues are stealing
all the limelights with all the cheating
accusations of um in title Tuesdays and
whatnot uh so that's a Pity because I
think it's very fascinating what's
what's going on and um no no we are
still of course pay course course course
but you know the the petitions are the
petitions are not about that so that's
that's that's not that's a p but um was
very interesting because I have um it's
a very complex situation I can um try to
go for the circuit uh could have I mean
try to go for circuit uh the well yeah
I'm leading as long as Wesley isn't
finishing um above second
here uh so I thought that um yeah I
should have gone for it and U you know I
mean I should I should try to do well in
the tournament so icluded that winning
is better than drawing and drawing is
better than loss as as usual but yeah um
yesterday I have to say um I sort of you
know ignited a lot of complications but
um I mean I have to say lir played very
well
um I should have done better I think I
could have made a draw even in the end
uh I missed the beautiful idea which is
I already thought I'm losing and then
still in the end just um before the
final um before I'm already lost I still
have a chance and actually then I think
that he would have um settled for a draw
because it's very complex and that was a
clear repetition there mhm so yeah I
could have played better yesterday but
um overall still very exciting situation
now with yeah everybody's so close in
the circuit and in the rating list as
well um and also you know I'm not
intending to do anything odd I'll play
normal tournaments but um uh it's
possible also to try and um get some
extra rating points like try to play
some um some extra events um yeah I know
it's getting tricky yeah I think that
shouldn't be like that like there should
be some sort of some sort of a set of
rules that would avoid it because then
in the end you can start to like yeah
try to artificially do some weird things
which is fair but just still um yeah
makes it very very odd but uh yeah it's
nice that it's so Clos and I think games
today are exciting and unlike yesterday
yesterday was like the nightmare
scenario for me I not only lost but also
W Wesley won which was very bad for me
uh today though it looks like
everything's going quite well so far uh
I think Wesley is under a lot of
pressure I mean I see this uh I see this
sacrifice on F7 I I mean I was very
confused
because I had a game with Duda
um I have to see it from the start this
opening because there is a line like
this where they go B6 and
bc5 it is very much similar to this but
maybe it's not this because here after
Queen F3 it seems like w was in trouble
so fab somehow move ordered te I was
just trying to understand it seems this
game is more exciting for than your own
game yes for sure no because it's very
very exciting so C Knight E2
D5 E3 Bishop A5
uhuh B see DC that's I think the so far
so good Bishop D2 could it be B6
here B6 here maybe yeah we l Peter after
yes mix up Ian it's a funny mixup
because or it's not I don't know like
but suddenly like here the bishop on A5
is okay I guess he has to still try and
gamble this but yeah B4 is coming and B5
is a pawn down so he tried to so while
this game was happening the plane venue
you were checking what's what's going on
yeah I was no I mean my game is just uh
what about your yes let's come back to
yours very solid normally I play very
risky like I play Knight C6 we Knight F6
here which leads to also double
positions today I decided to play more
solid I just play Knight of six
immediately were you affected by the
result yesterday let's say you just
wanted to keep it calm um yeah I mean a
lot of uh thoughts I you know a lot of
things went into it I just liked you
know this U this position I've beaten
Fabiano here with white it's my favorite
position actually with both colors I
like to such positions I like you know
uh with both sides I'm happy with white
uh I'm happy with black I'm happy it's
nice you don't need to study too much if
you know position like that you know
it's just amazing like the opposite
color Bishop nothing's happening I beat
Fab actually very nicely in um he went
Queen d8 here in Bundesliga so I played
Bishop to B3 and um the one put Bishop
on H3 uh I I think it was good here like
here it it feels like I'm under some
pressure uh because uh it's hard for me
to solve the the tension in the center
like let's say I cannot really go B5
which would be desirable because of this
beautiful Knight A3 resource otherwise
I'd get B5 Knight on B5 it's um very
very unpleasant so um yeah I also should
never go really CD CD because uh it
doesn't help and again like if I do
something like this it only makes things
worse because now he's getting very
active so all these Central operations
are not good but instead I think this
plan of G6 followed by King G7 and then
H5 usually in position like this you
have to make one um uh one active move
and opponent is
already terrified it's already terrified
because position like this white is so
risk free but moment you go H5 H4
already white is like okay get it's
getting too risky time make I I thought
he here I felt he's a little better but
um after R D3 he's lost a little
coordination I mean I could go B5 I be a
be Queen B5 I think white is slightly
better very very very very very slightly
better here so I went through dc8 it was
very interesting I'm trying to uh ignite
some um
complications I was going to calculate
this business you're discussing with
leavon r G3 CD Now this Knight A3 move U
DC A6 knight4 but Leon man knight4 right
away which is probably better and I
guess it's it's okay of course white
does want to enter such complications uh
he can try to go D5 but I think after D5
I was going to go Knight G4 and um I
have um also some ideas with Knight E8
Knight D6 maybe like a lot of I have a
lot of uh play here with the H file and
uh yeah he's he's this pro pass one is a
very longterm asset which is hard to
believe Anish I mean the game they
finished in a draw you decided to repeat
I have a question for you tomorrow is
the more important day you play with
Fabby what are your thoughts with white
pie um it looks
like uh I was afraid of that situation
already but it might we are entering a
situation where it might be better for
M's chances to lose than to drone my
gosh yeah no it is fascinating I against
fa yes for example against Fabi already
uh it could very well be because then um
I make him shoot higher yes above Wesley
which is um which could be important uh
so obviously that creates messed up
situation because um yeah I mean of
course I'm
never um you know going to play for a
loss or anything like that I'm not
absolutely but it just creates Kind of a
Funny Absolut crazy situation I mean I
are really looking forward for this game
tomorrow I mean all the best of luck for
okay just just you know maybe not
somehow I lose that game it's just
because I'm really stupid not because
I'm doing it on purpose but yeah I'm
really curious um I think it depends a
lot on this like if Wesley holds today
he is still in a good shape but if he
loses get very very exciting yeah thank
you so much Anish I'm really looking
forward for this game hope to see you
tomorrow you're afraid I'm already
talking too much you're afraid next
you're afraid jeopardize the entire
Integrity of the the game no no so okay
thank you so much and it's time to go
back to the
studio